so we're going to talk about the t word
the deadline to file your taxes is
looming experts say things are going
more smoothly though with the irs than
in recent pandemic years but an
estimated listen to this 80 million
people are still waiting until the very
last minute john langler takes a closer
look
the tax deadline is this coming monday
you just have a few days left to finish
all that paperwork with the unique
circumstances of the pandemic the
paperwork is more complicated than ever
makita abraham is down to the wire
repairing her taxes how much do we get
back for child care what don't we you
know what's out of our pocket like what
is the government doing for us all right
girls abraham and her husband had three
children in three years they also run
their own businesses all are factors
affecting their tax filings a jackson
hewitt survey conducted last month found
21 percent of respondents who waited to
file are too confused about their
personal tax situation another 21
percent think they owe money and 15
thought the deadline would be pushed
back again i'm here to tell you that is
not going to happen this year mark
stieber is with tax preparation service
jackson hewitt he says while 2021 is the
most complicated tax year he's seen in
decades refunds are up and refund sizes
are up three out of four taxpayers are
getting a tax refund and that's very
good news stieber says there are a lot
of benefits on the table but navigating
the complications may require help
child credit dependent care credit
earned income credit education credits
those are all big all complicated all
very pro tax payer but they're not
automatic check a box and get a big
check there are steps all taxpayers can
do to make the process smoother be
accurate don't guess estimate or expect
the irs to fix your mistakes file
electronically and electronically
deposit your tax refund
abraham says her family is actually
still waiting on last year's returns but
she's already looking to change her
approach in the future
as soon as we get our w-2s we are going
to file experts say next year could also
be chaotic a lot of the 2021 rules are
not in place for
2022 and taxpayers you may have some
sticker shock on those refunds a year
from now
john langley live local now